Vamos a hacer varios ejercicios de la línea
recta, pero esta vez visto en la forma punto-pendiente.
En esta vez vamos a ver la forma punto-pendiente
y, ¿qué es eso?
Bueno, lo que quiero que recordemos antes
es que ya hemos visto varios videos
y varios ejemplos de la forma
pendiente-ordenada al origen.
Que si tu te acuerdas un poco, la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen o la forma pendiente intersección
con el eje de las "y", es de la forma "y"
es igual a "mx" más "b",
donde "m" era la pendiente y "b"
la intersección con el eje de las "y".
Y ojo, lo que vamos a ver hoy, en la forma
punto-pendiente es exactamente equivalente
a esto, solamente que es otra forma de ver las cosas.
¿Cómo es la forma punto-pendiente?
Bueno, voy a escribir aquí la ecuación,
"y" menos "y1" es igual... y ahorita vas a
ver qué es "y1"... es igual a "m" que multiplica
a "x" menos "x1", donde "x1" y "y1" es el
punto que no dan,
son las coordenadas del punto que nos dan.
Es por eso que se llama punto-pendiente.
Y una de las cosas que si quiero que analicemos
bastante en este video, es que estas dos formas
de ver a la línea recta, son equivalentes.
Yo puedo pasar de la forma punto-pendiente
a la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen y
viceversa, es decir,
puedo ir de una a otra y de la otra a la una.
Vamos a hablar de la misma recta,
solamente que vista de dos maneras distintas.
Así que vamos a ver el primer ejercicio.
Dice que la pendiente es igual a -1/10 y además
pasa por el punto 10, 2.
Entonces déjame ponerlo aquí, nos dan un
punto por el cual pasa mi recta
que es el 10, 2... el 10, 2.
Y bueno, pues entonces ya tenemos un punto
y ya tenemos una pendiente pues vamos a usar
la ecuación de la recta de la forma punto-pendiente
que dice, "y" menos "y1"... y "y1" es el valor
de "y"que nos dan de este punto, es decir
"y" menos 2 es igual a -1/10 que es la pendiente,
que multiplica a "x" menos,
el valor que nos dan de "x" en este punto,
es decir, 10, "x" menos 10.
Y ya está, así de fácil y de sencillo podemos
encontrar a la recta en su forma punto pendiente,
"y" menos 2 es igual a -1/10 que multiplica
a "x" menos 10...
y es que fíjate, aquí hay algo muy importante,
esto sale de la misma definición de pendiente,
porque qué pasa si yo divido todo entre "x"
menos 10, pues me quedaría "y" menos 2
entre "x" menos 10, esto es exactamente igual a -1/10.
Y esto quiere decir que la diferencia de "y"entre
la diferencia de "x" es igual a -1/10, que
el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x" es
igual a -1/10, delta de "y" entre delta de "x",
que es la definición de pendiente o
dicho de otra manera, cualquier otro punto
que te tomes de esta línea recta si tú te
fijas el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x"
te tiene que dar, - 1/10 y es exactamente
la definición de una línea recta cuya pendiente
es -1/10 y además que pase por el punto 10, 2.
Es decir, que esta ecuación punto-pendiente
sale de la definición de la pendiente de una recta.
Y bueno, ya que tenemos esta ecuación
de la forma punto-pendiente,
lo que quiero que veas es que si la manipulamos
de una manera algebraica,
podemos llegar a la forma
pendiente-ordenada al origen.
Porque fíjate bien, qué va a pasar si yo distribuyo
este -1/10, me va a quedar,
-1/10 por "x" y después -1/10 por -10,
menos por menos me da más,
10 entre 10 me da 1 y si ahora sumo 2 de ambos lados de la ecuación me queda que "y" es igual a -1/10 de "x"
más 3 y date cuenta que aquí ya lo tenemos de la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen,
donde la pendiente es igual a -1/10 y la ordenada al origen es más 3 y ya pasé de uno a otro.
Así que vamos a hacer otro ejercicio.
Encontremos la ecuación de la línea que
contiene a los puntos 10, 12 y 5, 25.
Así que lo primero que voy a sacar es la
pendiente y la pendiente es igual
¿a quien? al cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x".
Por lo tanto vamos a calcular el cambio en "y", me voy a tomar a éste como punto final y me queda 12 menos 25,
"y2" menos "y1", y a esto hay que dividirlo entre 10, ojo,
si este es el punto final, tiene coordenadas "x2", "y2".
Por lo tanto hay que tener cuidado con el orden y el 12 tiene que quedar abajo del 10,
entonces, 12 menos 25 entre 10 menos 5.
¿Y cuánto es esto?
Pues 12 menos 25 es -13.
Y después, 10 menos 5 es 5.
Entonces mi pendiente es -13/5.
La pendiente es muy importante encontrarla,
porque recuerda que nuestra nueva forma de
ver la línea recta, es la forma punto-pendiente,
entonces ya tengo la pendiente y ahora
voy a utilizar uno de los puntos y me queda que
"y" menos 25 es igual a -13/5 de "x" menos 5.
"y" menos "y1" es igual a "m" que multiplica a "x" menos "x1", estoy usando el punto 5, 25.
Pero ojo, de igual manera pude haber utilizado
el otro punto, porque al final recuerda que
tanto un punto como el otro punto existen
en tu línea recta y ya está.
Ya tenemos aquí a esta ecuación de la recta
de la forma punto-pendiente.
Así que bueno, ya tenemos un ejercicio más
y pues creo que vamos a buen tiempo
para hacer otro ejercicio, dice.
Y el siguiente ejercicio dice, la recta tiene una pendiente de 3/5 y además intersecta al eje "y" en -3.
Y bueno, si te das cuenta aquí tenemos la
pendiente y la intersección con el eje de las "y",
sería muy fácil encontrar la ecuación
pendiente-ordenada de origen,
porque ya nos dan todos los datos, es decir,
"y" es igual a "mx" más "b"
y nos quedaría que "y" es igual a 3/5 de "x" menos 3.
Sin embargo, yo lo que quiero encontrar en este ejercicio es la forma punto-pendiente,
así que, cómo le vamos a hacer para encontrar la ecuación de la recta por la forma punto-pendiente...
punto-pendiente.
Y bueno, tenemos la pendiente, la pendiente
es de 3/5, por lo tanto "m" vale 3/5 y bueno,
la pregunta va a ser,
¿cómo encontramos un punto de esta línea recta?
Sin embargo, tampoco está tan difícil porque yo sé que ésta recta intersecta al eje de las "y" en el punto, 0, -3.
Nos dicen que esta recta intersecta al eje
de las "y" en -3.
Es decir, que cuando "x" vale 0, "y" vale -3.
Por lo tanto, esta recta para por el punto 0, -3.
Y entonces, ya tengo un punto, ya tengo una
pendiente, ya puedo usar
la ecuación de la recta en la forma punto-pendiente.
¿Y qué me va a quedar?
"y" menos "y1" es igual a "m" por "x" menos "x1".
Por lo tanto me va a quedar "y" menos "y1",
pero "y 1" vale -3, entonces "y"menos -3,
esto es igual a "m", "m" vale 3/5 que multiplica
a "x" menos "x1", es decir, 0, "x" menos 0,
pero aquí tengo menos -3, esto es exactamente
lo mismo que tener más 3,
es decir "y" más 3 es igual a 3/5 por "x" menos 0...
por "x" menos 0.
Ahora date cuenta de algo, si yo a "x"le quito
0, me sigue quedando "x",
por lo tanto esto lo puedo escribir de la siguiente manera, esto es exactamente lo mismo que tener,
"y" más 3, es igual a 3/5 de "x".
Y ya está, aquí tenemos la solución de
esta ecuación de la forma punto-pendiente.
Aunque tal vez aquí no se vea tan claro en
el resultado final, cual es el punto, pero
ya con esto redujimos un poco la ecuación
de la recta punto-pendiente.
Ahora fíjate bien, si yo resto menos 3 de ambos lados
de la ecuación, llegó a la ecuación
de la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen,
me quedaría que este 3 se pasa del
otro lado de la ecuación
y me queda que "y" es igual a 3/5 de "x" menos 3.
Así que vamos a hacer el último ejercicio,
que dice, "f" de -7 es igual a 5 y "f" de
3 es igual a -4.
Y aquí tenemos puntos de la forma "x", "f"
de "x", donde "x" es lo que está dentro del paréntesis,
es decir, -7 y "f" de "x" es,
el valor que está a la derecha de esta igualdad,
en este caso es 5.
Ya tenemos un punto, el punto -7, 5
y el otro punto sería el 3, -4, "x" vale 3 y "f" de
"x" vale -4 y bueno, ya así tenemos dos puntos,
por lo tanto ya puedo encontrar la pendiente
de esta recta.
Recuerda que la pendiente es la diferencia
de "y" entre la diferencia de "x"
o el cambio de "y" entre el cambio de "x" o "y2" menos "y1", es decir -4 menos 5, entre 3 menos -7... 3 menos -7,
que es el otro valor de "x", el valor del punto inicial.
¿Y qué me queda aquí?
-4 menos 5 es -9 y 3 menos -7, es lo mismo
que 3 más 7, lo cual es 10.
Por lo tanto, me quedan -9/10.
Y ya tengo la pendiente y tengo además dos
puntos, por lo tanto, puedo usar cualquiera
de estos dos puntos porque ambos viven en
mi línea recta para poner la ecuación
de la recta en la forma punto-pendiente,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
"y" menos... y me voy a tomar este punto de
aquí... "y" menos -4, que es el valor de "y",
esto tiene que ser igual a la pendiente
que es -9/10, es decir, -9/10, que multiplica
¿a quién? a "x" menos "x1", es decir, "x" menos 3.
"y" menos -4 es igual a -9/10 de "x" menos
3, recuerda que este caso solamente necesitamos
un punto y una pendiente.
Y aquí podemos simplificar un poco,
menos por menos me da más y me va a quedar que
"y" más 4 es exactamente igual a -9/10,
que multiplica a "x" menos 3.
Y ya está, aquí tenemos la solución
también de este ejercicio.